[Music]
i
am charlotte stick and i'm co-founder
and ceo of handbag clinic
today i'm going to walk you through how
our artisan chloe will restore
this grand chopper tote that has had pen
ink all over it
the chanel grand shopper tote reached
around
2000 pounds when it was able to be
bought direct from chanel
when this restoration's complete we
would sell a grand shopper tote
for anywhere between 1 700 pounds
and 1 950 pounds
[Music]
the first thing that chloe will do with
this item is
remove all of the ink the most important
part
of restoring this bag will actually be
the initial cleaning because ink can
spread
and can create more staining
we use a special ink remover so you can
see
chloe taking the ink remover with a
small cotton bud
and gently rolling this over the initial
ink
this is so that we don't have any
spreading any further contamination of
that ink
to the bag one of the main reasons for
this
is because ink is actually very oily and
oil and leather really don't mix
[Music]
we then also use a range of products
some
are solvent-based which will help to dry
out
any areas which have absorbed additional
oils
and then we also use products which have
natural oils embedded into them
which will then nourish areas that have
dried such as the corners
and or any areas where the ink has been
drawn out of
[Music]
we then use our specialist cleaning
solution
with the brush and a foam which then
will remove any excess product
caviar skin leather is grained so you
need the brush to get into
all of those grooves to be able to
really make sure it's clean and make
sure it's ready for the next stage of
the process
caviar leather it gets its name from
being a petal
texture leather which means that it has
printed into it
this almost bubbles effect if anything
is trapped there or left in there
you would run the risk of that later
peeling or coming away
[Music]
because it is ink that is contaminated
with this the cleaning process alone
will not remove this stain and we must
apply other methods
[Music]
in our research and development team we
realized that
ink stains in particular were very
stubborn
so we created a metallic solution which
actually blocks that coming through to
make sure in
a year's time you're not going to start
seeing that ink stain come through
chloe takes the specialist solution and
she applies it lightly
with an airbrush throughout every area
where you can see the ink
chloe will then create the color match
which we have discussed
with the client in advance
this colorant once created will then be
averaged on this bag
we always want to be as sparing as
possible to
ensure the texture of the leather is
maintained
because of the iconic cc quilting and
the cc on the front of the item which
makes this
item the iconic chanel look we want to
make sure as
little pigment gets onto those stitches
as possible
the bag is ready to go
[Music]
you